public sénat france 24 et rfi présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour la rentrée dit si l'europe rentrée
européenne pour le moins anxiogène sur
fond de guerre en ukraine flambée des
prix nécessité pour les européens de
resserrer les rangs alors que certains
pays pourraient être tentés par
l'extrême droite voilà pourquoi nous
recevons aujourd'hui pour un premier
tour d'horizon européen laurence boone
la nouvelle secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'europe du gouvernement avec un profil
d'ailleurs un peu inhabituel à bonjour
madame bonne au genre avant votre
arrivée au gouvernement vous avez été
l'économiste en chef puis la secrétaire
générale adjointe de l'eau cda le club
des démocraties libérales auparavant
vous avez conseillé sur le plan
économique et financier le président
françois hollande économiste classé dans
la famille des keynésiens vous avez
aussi dans une première vie travailler
dans le secteur privé pour des grandes
banques d'investissement barclays
merrill lynch et en 2019 vous
apparaissez dans la liste des 50
français et françaises les plus
influents du monde un classement établi
par le magazine vanity fair alors parmi
les personnalités les plus influentes au
monde bien sûr on pense à la reine
d'angleterre qui s'est éteinte jeudi
dans sa résidence de balmoral le royaume
uni et le monde la pleurent qu'est-ce
que vous obtiendriez finalement de cette
personnalité cette souveraine aux 70 ans
de règne dans l'histoire à titre
personnel en comme vous le soulignez
j'ai passé dix ans de ma vie en
angleterre et donc une certaine
tristesse du goutier un bâti pour le
peuple à la fois britannique et du
commonwealth et dans son ensemble
est ce qu'elle symbolise vraiment je
crois c'est la force des institutions la
capacité d'une femme à rester la garante
de l'unité de son pays au delà de son
pays quel que soit le système politique
elle qui était allé les aléas
économiques et financiers et du royaume
uni de gagner un énorme respect impôts
vraiment le dévouement de cette femme de
sa famille pour cette tâche et puis et
puis elle représente
l'ancrage des institutions qui permet à
des pays de traversier à toutes les
tempêtes est alors moins heureux avant
de disparaître c'est garante des
institutions comme vous le soulignez et
bien elle a pris le temps de nommer une
autre femme première ministre du
royaume-uni l'ultralibéral propres exit
liste ross celle qui se veut un peu la
nouvelle margaret thatcher n'est pas
tout à fait sûrs d'être ami de la france
elle a hésité sur le terme quand on lui
a posé des questions ci était avant sa
nomination vous attend dès aujourd'hui
un bras de fer avec elle sur la question
du traité du divorce et du breakbeat et
bien sûr sur la question des migrants
qui transitent par calais écoutez il ya
deux choses la première
est liée à la femme en campagne et puis
maintenant il ya la première ministre
qui vient de faire son gouvernement
ellis trust elle est confrontée aux
mêmes problèmes que nous la guerre que
la russie mène contre l'ukraine et ses
conséquences qui parmi les conséquences
notamment l'explosion des factures
énergétiques et moi je voudrais retenir
deux choses sur les factures
énergétiques c'est la tension sociale on
comprend que ça crée elle c'est la
première action de son gouvernement dont
vous voyez elle est concernée par le
bien-être de sa population comme souvent
la deuxième choix aussi face à la russie
le royaume-uni est avec nous au sein du
g7 il est avec nous pour soutenir
l'ukraine militairement économiquement
financièrement et elle est aussi avec
nous dans les sanctions contre la russie
et pour protéger les démocraties donc je
crois qu'on va trouver des terrains
d'entente le risque de récession
augmentent pour l'union européenne selon
la commission en raison de la flambée
des prix notamment évidemment des prix
de l'énergie est ce qu'on risque
finalement une rentrée de grogne sociale
partout en europe voire une contestation
populaire justement des sanctions de
l'union européenne contre la russie mais
c'est vrai que il y a un problème avec
les prix de l'énergie qui touche toutes
les populations du continent européen
maintenant va on va remettre les choses
dans le contexte on a d'abord eu le coc
vide le coc vide la chine a fermé et les
prix des matières premières ont flambé
et ensuite la russie qui attaquent le
cren militairement et qui crée une
catastrophe humanitaire et la russie qui
en fait attaque le système démocratique
en jouant avec le prix du gaz donc en
fait la russie sait très bien ce qu'elle
fait elle fait monter le prix du gaz est
le fait lieu le yoyo avec les flux de
gaz à travers north stream pour nous
pénaliser pour faire plier nos
populations et c'est vraiment une guerre
de son autocratie contre nos démocraties
et donc nous qu'est ce qu'on fait mais
nous on va réagir à la fois pour la
première des choses c'est protéger les
populations puisque on veut gagner cette
guerre démocratique et donc pour ça il
ya eu le bouclier sanitaire il ya les
prix du gaz d'électricité qui ont bloqué
ensuite il ya une réaction en européen
pour s'assurer que tout le monde et de
l'énergie cet hiver et puis une
accélération de la transition
énergétique pour sortir de cette
dépendance vis-à-vis de la russie les
cours du gaz s'élevait fin août à 15
fois à leurs niveaux d'avant la pandémie
de kobe de 19 les ministres de l'énergie
étaient réunis en sommet ce vendredi à
prague pour en débattre ursula von der
leyen présentera sa vision finalisé
d'ailleurs mardi à quoi servirait par
exemple pour nos téléspectateurs un
fameux plafonnement des prix des gaz et
du pétrole contre évidemment lequel
beaucoup ce coût se récrie 1 alors il
visait il visait à deux choses la
première c'est effectivement un baisser
les prix et vous savez que les prix du
lait électricité sont liées au prix du
gaz en europe donc si on arrive à
plafonner les prix du gaz on va aussi
plafonner les prix d'électricité et puis
la deuxième chose c'est de diminuer les
revenus qui vont vers la russie si on
plafonne les prix du gaz russe si on
leur dit ban puisque vous fait joujou
avec le gaz un jour je vous en passe un
jour je vous en passe pas nous en fait
on va payer que ça et du coup on va
alors les privé d'une manne financière
c'est vraiment l'objectif l'europe qui a
réussi à mutualiser ses achats de
vaccins est ce qu'il pourra le faire
pour le gaz est ce que c'est une option
est ici c'est en avait pas une pourquoi
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour alors
c'est une option de mutualiser en fait
il ya une plateforme qui pour l'instant
est volontaire d'achat commun de gaz est
l'intérêt de cette plateforme d'achat
commun c'est que comme pour les vaccins
si on est plus nombreux on est plus fort
et on peut négocier mieux à la fois le
prix auquel on achète le gaz et pas
seulement avec la russie mais aussi avec
d'autres fournisseurs comme la norvège
ou l'algérie et les quantités donc oui
cette plateforme est discutée
aujourd'hui avec dans l'objectif
d'accroître notre pouvoir de négociation
à la fois sur les quantités et sur le
prix du gaz il ya des conseils des chefs
d'état et gouvernement en octobre donc
je pense que ça va aller très vite
emmanuel macron a fait sa rentrée en
prédisant à la fin de l'abondance ça
fait couler beaucoup d'encre les
vingt-sept doivent se préparer à réduire
notamment leur consommation
d'électricité de 5% lors des pics de
consommation ce qui coûte finalement le
plus cher est ce que vous êtes favorable
à ce que cette finalement pénurie
d'électricité organisé soit obligatoire
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on fasse
tous des efforts je pense qu'il faut
regarder l'objectif qu'on est en train
d'essayer d'atteindre l'objectif qu'on
veut atteindre c'est que tout le monde
puisse utiliser de l'électricité pour
cet hiver et à un prix raisonnable
et pour faire ça
réduire la consommation c'est un des
outils pour qu'on a c'est réduire la
consommation c'est plafonné l'évolution
du prix de l'électricité ce que le
gouvernement quand c'est fait et c'est
s'assurer qu'on aura du gaz à un prix
raisonnable également puisqu'on en a
besoin pour faire d'électricité alors
parmi les outils iavi dément ce bouclier
énergétique pour aider les ménages il
faut le financer les pays européens
beaucoup d'entre eux sont déjà très
endetté d'où l'idée d'une taxe sur les
super profits
le président macro n'y étaient pas
favorables finalement il s'en remet à la
décision de bruxelles c'est taxe c'est 7
c'est super profits on sait pas toujours
exactement ce que c'est mais en gros ce
sont les énergéticiens qui ont gagné
beaucoup d'argent parce que les prix du
gaz et de l'électricité ont beaucoup
augmenté
sur le principe en tant que économistes
est ce que vous êtes favorable à cet
impôt vous avez dit une phrase qui a
amené hui est typique had à quel point
se trompe de débat vous avez dit on sait
pas très bien ce que c'est mais c'est
exactement ça alors je vais vous
répondre très simplement il ya des pays
pour lesquels c'est bien d'avoir une
taxe sur les super profits parce qu'ils
ont des entreprises productrices
d'énergie qui font des super profits et
il y avait le cas en france de total
énergie mais tout de total on lui a déjà
demandé de baisser ses prix je vous
rappelle qu'on payait 2 euros le litre
d'essence cet été et qu'on le paye 1
euro 50 pour moi l'objectif c'est quoi
l'objectif c'est que les consommateurs
les usagers vous moi et les entreprises
on est de l'énergie cet hiver et à un
prix raisonnable
c'est ça l'objectif est-ce que ça c'est
loin d'atteindre l'objectif et ben non
pas toujours le meilleur moyen
d'atteindre l'objectif c'est de baisser
les prix de production et ça c'est la
mesure principale avec le mécanisme de
compensation de qui est sur la table
c'est que par la contribution qu'on va
prélever sur tous les producteurs
d'énergie c'est ce qui est discuté
aujourd'hui on va pouvoir reverser cet
argent aux usagers pour faire diminuer
la facture énergétique
je crois que ça doit être notre compte à
parlons si vous le voulez bien laurence
boone des européens qui doivent qui ne
doivent absolument pas se diviser sur
l'ukraine est garant longtemps de cette
unité le tandem franco allemand c'est un
nouveau tandem olaf scholz c'est un
chancelier qui a démarré son mandat un
peu affaibli par les contradictions de
sa propre coalition sur l'ukraine savas
hésitation perso elle est un peu idem
pour emmanuel macron n'en veut dire avec
une majorité toute relative est-ce que
avec deux chefs d'état un peu affaibli
la locomotive européenne la fameuse
locomotive du tandem franco-allemand
elle n'est pas sacrément affaibli moi
j'aimerais bien que de temps en temps on
arrête de regarder le verre à moitié
vide et qu'on regarde verre à moitié
plein en fait il ya croyait deux chefs
d'état qui sont élus et qui n'ont pas
d'élections nationales pendant trois ans
et ça ça veut dire trois ans dans lequel
ils peuvent construire et
amplifier le franco-allemand on à ce
sujet d'énergie on a lu sujet ukrainien
on a le sujet élargissement on a le
sujet état de droit à l'état de droit à
ces l'indépendance des juges et les
processus démocratiques qui fonctionne
c'est la pluralité des médias sur
lesquels il faut qu'on travaille en
européen on a des élections européennes
on a un chantier devant nous et deux
chefs d'état avec suffisamment de temps
pour ces pour s'y attaquer mois des
élections européennes en 2024 précisant
pauvres alors justement vous évoqué
l'élargissement il y a donc la première
réunion de cette communauté politique
européenne qui aura lieu début octobre
vous l'avez évoqué laurence boone les
balkans le flanc est seront invités à la
table des discussions
mais là dessus on voit justement qu'il y
a une différence entre berlin et paris
avec un chancelier qui est très
favorable à l'élargissement il l'a
rappelé récemment en revanche emmanuel
macron reste sur la réserve là dessus à
nouveau je pense que c'est n'est pas
juste c'est la france avec la présence à
la présidence française de l'union
européenne qui a poussé à l ukraine pour
quel est le statut d'adhérent pareil
pour la moldavie donc la france non
seulement n'est pas contre
l'élargissement mais elle agit en faveur
de l'élargissement ça c'est la première
chose et la communauté politique
européenne c'est quoi ces encres et tous
les pays qui sont au voisinage de
l'union européenne à l'union européenne
tous ces pays pour qu'on partage pour
qu'on fasse une vraie zone démocratique
à nouveau qui puisse résister à
l'impérialisme russe un possible
désunion des vingt-sept là pour le coup
deux clubs européens on constate une
forte poussée de l'extrême droite en
suède
lors des élections du 11 septembre et en
italie la néo fasciste géorgien meloni
est en tête des intentions de vote pour
le scrutin du 25 septembre
elle pourrait donc devenir chef de
gouvernement appuyé d'ailleurs sur deux
parties qui sont plutôt pro-russe est-ce
qu'il faut s'attendre ce craindre un
revirement diplomatique
bon alors je vais pas faire de
prévisions politique je crois que c'est
encore plus difficile que les prévisions
économiques
je vais dire deux choses vous me parliez
de l'angleterre on a vu en angleterre
des partis politiques de gauche de
droite passée repassée et l'amitié entre
les peuples est tout ce qui nous unit à
fait que ça va continuer c'est la même
chose avec l'italie la société civile le
milieu économique financiers les
administrations travaillent ensemble
depuis toujours je vous donne un exemple
il ya une diplomate italienne au
ministère que j'ai l'honneur de servir
nous avons signé l'italie a signé le
traité du quirinal qui un traité qui
consolide en structure les relations
entre eux l italie la france à nouveau à
tous les échelons les les personnes les
citoyens les administrations le milieu
des affaires l'italie fait partie est un
des pays fondateurs avec la france de
l'union européenne donc l'extrême droite
au pouvoir c'est ça serait pas un énorme
choc pour l'union européenne à la tête
du gouvernement par le personne souhaite
en tous les cas je parle pour moi et
pour le gouvernement l'extrême droite
voir ce que j'essaye de vous dire
puisqu'on parle d'état de droit en
général c'est très abstrait c'est
vraiment très petit si les institutions
les institutions italiennes et
européennes sont solides l'intérêt de
l'italie et de travailler avec la france
et l'europe est l'intérêt de la france
et de l'europe et de travailler avec
l'italie et oui il y aura des sujets
délicats quand on parle ghazi
immigration bien sûr on sera pas
d'accord mais on sait se parler on a un
cadre pour se parler une toute dernière
crise question très rapidement viktor
orban le premier ministre hongrois
voulait que les sanctions contre 3
oligarques russes soient levés
finalement il a reculé est ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui le cheval de troie de dimur
poutine au sein de l'union européenne et
comment faut-il traiter avec lui alors
je remercie parce que ça me donne
l'occasion de parler de hongrie de
seconde la hongrie ne touche pas à
l'argent du plan de relance et la
hongrie européen pardon et la hongrie
est dans un mécanisme qu'on appelle
conditionnalité pourquoi parce qu'en
hongrie les juges ne sont pas
indépendants parce que la pluralité et
l'indépendance des médias n'est pas
respectée parce que le système anti
institutionnelle anticorruption en gros
de pas donné tous les contrats publics à
la même entreprise avec laquelle vous
d'être ami n'est pas respectée et donc
ça ça veut dire quoi pour la hongrie ça
veut dire qu'elles touchent pas de sou
des fonds de cohésion et elle ne touche
pas de sou des plans de relance tant
qu'elle n'améliore pas ses institutions
et quand on parle d' état de droit c'est
vraiment de ça dont on est en train de
parler donc on a des juges vous raconte
ça parce que on a des vrais leviers pour
garantir l'état de droit à l'intérieur
de l'union et ça rejoint les questions
que vous m'avez composé précédemment et
évidemment on voit la hongrie fait des
efforts elle fait beaucoup d'efforts
elle a mis en place maintenant une
agence anti corruption donc ce système
fonctionne elle est en train de faire
évoluer ses institutions pour les
aligner sur l'état
dans son discours à l'entrée alors il a
un discours qui est absolument
inacceptable sur les races et sur les
gens et c'est aussi pour ça qu'il ya ces
mécanismes mais ce que vous voyez c'est
qu'il est entré aujourd'hui au procès
enfin sa ministre ou son ministre est
entrée aujourd'hui au conseil des
ministres de l'énergie avec zéro a
priori sur le gaz c'est déjà un progrès
et ça va continuer merci à vous en tout
cas laurence boone d'avoir été est notre
invité aujourd'hui merci à tous de nous
avoir suivi on continue sur la question
de la rentrée mais cette fois-ci rentrée
scolaire avec notre grand débat au
parlement européen de bruxelles en
compagnie de public sénat
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre pour notre
rentrée au parlement européen ici à
bruxelles et en parlant de rentrée des
classes il y en a qui manquent à l'appel
un partout à travers l'europe ce sont
les enseignants en france ce ne sont pas
moins de 4000 postes vacants début
septembre plus encore en allemagne et en
italie et depuis la pandémie de covile
19 l'évocation aux chutes et nombreux
sont ceux qui ont démissionné et les
raisons sont multiples oui en cause
notamment bien sûr de faibles salaires
par rapport aux niveaux de qualification
dans certains pays mais dans d'autres
malgré des rémunérations correct le
manque de perspectives d'évolution de
reconnaissance ou la charge de travail
décourage les candidats professeur alors
europe ton éducation fous l'camp comment
former une jeunesse en manque de repères
sans profs qualifiée motivée nous allons
poser cette question à nos deux invités
du jour deux eurodéputés et sur notre
plateau quant à melchior eurodéputés
danoise du groupe renault europe
précisons que dans votre pays un
enseignant gagne presque deux fois plus
qu'un professeur français efface avoue
françois xavier bellamy un professeur de
philosophie mais également eurodéputée
un français du groupe ppe bonjour à tous
les deux mois alors on a plus de
problème de masques en effet ni de
courant distant ciel en cette rentrée
2022 ça c'est quand même la bonne
nouvelle mais on manque néanmoins un peu
partout de professeurs en europe comment
est ce qu'on explique ça
d'abord peut-être disons un mot de ce
que vous venez de dire qui est très
important de beaucoup de mes collègues
de beaucoup de chefs d'établissement
j'entends aujourd'hui remonter le
sentiment de la grande désespérance qui
touche beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui
les élèves vont mal
le coc vide malheureusement est passée
par là et l'expérience de ses années de
ces mois passés à distance laisse des
traces et je crois que c'est très
important au parlement européen on a eu
l'occasion de travailler sur un texte
sur la question de la santé mentale et
notamment de la santé mentale les plus
jeunes de réussir à prendre la mesure de
ce qui s'est joué en termes d' équilibre
personnel en termes aussi
d'apprentissage les américains ont
publié des universités américaines ont
publié une étude récemment sur le recul
du niveau de lecture à cause de cette
période de kovy des de confinement voilà
je pense qu'il faudra qu'on tire les
enseignements de tout cela pour les
professeurs ben écoutez je ne sais pas
s'il ya une leçon européenne de cette
crise des vocations en france en tous
les cas il est certain que cette crise
des vocations est liée à la
déconsidération qui pèse sur le métier d
enseignant depuis trop longtemps
maintenant qui passe par les salaires
extrêmement faibles dont les enseignants
français sont son sont l'objet un niveau
de rémunération qui est très bas même
par rapport à la moyenne de le céder
alors que le coût de la vie évidemment
plus important en france que dans la
moyenne de la cdo et caramel cordes
écrivez-nous peut-être la rentrée
scolaire chez vous au danemark l'édition
2022 il ya les restes et la difficulté
de la pandémie qui en encore très
présent surtout chez les jeunes qui sont
restés chez eux sans leurs amis des
puits parce que plus que deux ans mais
aussi un des demandes de partout des
parents des sociétés d élèves d l'état
des communes sur le professeur qui ont
leur demande d'éduquer nos enfants dans
tous les domaines de la vie mais en même
temps aussi j'aurais des problèmes
personnels
mon talent des jeunes sans avoir les
soutiens nécessaires pour leur travail
donc on leur demande de faire tout sans
vraiment leur donner l'espace d être
dément une professeure en france
effectivement 4000 enseignants qui
manquent à l'appel à l'issue des
concours début septembre on essaye d'en
trouver
très rapidement
on se retrouve d'ailleurs à recruter des
personnels sans les diplômes requis
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
mais rien que ça dit la déconsidération
du moment saignant dans mon académie
l'académie de versailles la plus grande
académie de france on se met à recruter
des professeurs avec des job dating ça
veut dire qu en une demi heure quelqu'un
qui vient postuler peut devenir
professeur en ayant suivi seulement
quelques heures de formation
vos collègues de plusieurs médias ont
fait des tests ou des caméras cachées
pour montrer la facilité avec laquelle
on se voyait confier ce que pourtant un
pays a de plus précieux c'est à dire sa
jeunesse des enfants mineurs qui se
retrouve devant des adultes qui n'ont
pas de formation pour pour cela et pour
tous ceux qui c'est mon cas ils sont
très nombreux ont passé des années à
étudier à se former à apprendre à passer
des concours exigeant ensuite suivre des
formations pour pouvoir devenir de des
enseignants et bien l'idée que vous
allez être rejoindre votre mission par
des gens et je ne leur reproche rien
évidemment ce n'est pas eux qui sont en
cause mais qui n'ont aucune formation
pour cela c'est dire finalement que
l'état votre employeur considère que
votre métier peuvent être assumées dans
n'importe quelles conditions et par
n'importe qui et c'est un signe de cette
déconsidération jeu je partage
totalement ce que vous disiez à
l'instant je crois qu'on n'a pas
autorisé les professeurs à faire
vraiment leur métier on n'a pas respecté
leur métier j'avais écrit en 2014 un
livre qui s'appelle les déshérités sur
la crise de la transmission qui venait
de ma propre expérience de professeur et
je crois que c'est d'abord une crise
intérieure ce une crise du sens même de
ce travail de sens et de considération
alors en france le salaire moyen d'un
enseignant est de 29 mille quatre cents
euros bruts annuels au danemark qui est
de 55 mille six cents euros et en
allemagne les de 60000 euros donc on
voit vraiment des deux grandes
disparités pourquoi les professeurs ils
sont ils sont bien mieux payés chez vous
est ce que ça veut dire que la
profession est les mieux considérés
socialement au danemark mais
il y a un bon salaire pour les
professeurs en danemark mais il n'y a
pas vraiment une envie de rester dans la
profession aussi pour les professeurs
nous avons une perte des 11 % des
professeurs dans les écoles publiques en
danemark il y à honda marco si il y à
des personnes qui vient remplacer des
professeurs sans avoir la formation de
professeurs qui est pas nécessairement
seulement une mauvaise chose il se donne
aussi plus des diversités et puis ces
diversités d'éducation mais les gens qui
ont peut-être à étudier des
mathématiques dans les universités mais
ce ne sont pas des profs n'ont qu'une
compréhension pédagogiques qui sont
nécessaires dans les écoles il ya un
problème de formation c'est ça vous nous
disiez un problème de formation il ya
aussi un problème des formes des niveaux
de formation chez le professeur parce
qu'ils n'ont pas vraiment des
compétences approfondies dont léa
mercière dans le substance du daim noir
des langues les sciences naturelles les
maths qui sont nécessaires pour mettre
au niveau les jeunes dès leur homme il y
a la possibilité de faire des échanges
aussi pour les professeurs à travers
l'europe des champs solaires des
échanges pédagogiques ou si le mot tu es
qui a qui étaient cousus utilisé pendant
la pandémie et la distance y l1 le mans
dans existentielle mais pour les
échanges entre les professeurs dans nos
différents pays européens qui leur
permet d évoluer quand professeurs avec
des inspirations des autres pays mais
mais mais quand on parle de manque de
considération
on pense en effet à l'évolution carrière
il n'arrive pas à se projeter finalement
dans le futur autrement que professeur
et puis peut-être aussi les parents qui
sont qui sont devenus maintenant un peu
difficile avec les professeurs qui
demandent des meilleures notes c'est ça
ou c'est aussi que les en tout cas honda
marquillies à en plateforme digitale qui
mettent très proche les professeurs et
les parents
et qui donne des difficultés des respect
de l'autorité des professeurs est aussi
que les parents veulent se mêler dans
tous les pays et chose qui se passe à
l'école et je trouve c'est nécessaire
des données la place pour le professeur
de vraiment prendre en charge leur rôle
nous connaissons une hyperinflation en
europe est-ce qu'en france on va
compenser pour les professeurs avec une
hausse des salaires générale pour leur
assurer un minimum de pouvoir d'achat
notamment il ya la question du logement
elle est un professeur qui commence à
enseigner ne peut évidemment pas se
loger là où il enseigne s'il enseigne
dans des grandes villes ou dans des
effectivement dans les métropoles
la grande difficulté du ministère de
l'éducation nationale c'est en france je
crois le deuxième plus gros employeurs
au monde après l'armée chinoise c'est à
dire la deuxième organisation aussi
centralisé de ressources humaines le
ministère l'éducation nationale c'est un
million de fonctionnaires dont 850 mille
professeurs et donc tous les mouvements
sont très long très lourds très
compliqué c'est une vraie question sur
la manière dont notre modèle structuré
et s'organisent et je crois qu'il faut
absolument qu'on puisse faire un choix
de société décisif aujourd'hui il ya la
question des mesures d'urgence dans le
contexte de l'inflation mais il ya
surtout la question de la vision que
nous avons à long terme de notre pays de
notre continent européen l'europe s'est
construite sur la culture elle s'est
construite sur l'intelligence et elle ne
réussira à tirer son épingle du jeu dans
la mondialisation que par l'intelligence
le savoir et le niveau de connaissances
des générations futures l'europe n'a pas
des matériaux l'europe n'a pas dé de
pétrole elle n'a pas de d'hydrocarbures
si nous voulons réussir à assurer la
prospérité de notre continent de
l'avenir si nous voulons relever aussi
les grands défis auxquels nous sommes
confrontés aux défis climatiques
environnementales les défis
technologiques majeures qui sont devant
nous eh bien il faut que nous ayons une
capacité d'investir massivement dans la
formation des jeunes générations
aujourd'hui nous sommes très très loin
du compte je pense en france en
particulier décrochage notre système
éducatif est absolument manifester l'un
des signaux les plus inquiétants pour la
trêve mais même dans des classements
pisias pisa dont qui mesure le niveau
des élèves on se rend compte que le
niveau global est en train de chuter
alors c'est vrai il ya eu deux enfants
daigné c'est aussi lié peut-être
justement à la charge de deux
professeurs moins qualifiés peut-être
moins motivés peut-être mais je crois
aussi il faut pas rester trop fixé sur
les les mesures des pizzas il y a
l'effet qu'il faudra apprendre des faits
et des méthodes
des formulaires en mathématiques mais
c'est aussi en question
ddd former les jeunes à penser eux-mêmes
et d'avoir un indépendant ce au niveau
de l'apprentissage pour rencontrer une
monde qui change très vite et donc c'est
pas laissé une grande centralisation des
cursus et des méthodes pour l'éducation
n'est pas une bonne chose on a une
grande discussion pour mettre plus
libres les écoles en danemark pour que
les professeurs l'école
individuels peuvent faire des choix est
nécessaire pour les jeunes chez eux qui
est plus d'autonomie plus d'autonomie et
pour les futurs pour notre continent il
faut vraiment investir dans les
personnes qui qui s'engage avec les
autres humains les professeurs les
infirmières les pédagogues parce qu'on a
en idées de toujours mettre moins de fin
pour les maisons pour les communes pour
les municipalités
et dans l'éducation et c'est vraiment là
seuls endroits où on ne peut pas
vraiment imaginer une automatisation
plus d'efficacité avec les dj
salinisation et donc on à l'article l
intelligence artificielle et qui peut
nous aider mais ça va pas changer les
relations humaines françois-xavier
bellamy on peut quand même en effet se
poser la question des répercussions des
conséquences de moins d'enseignants
moins bien formés pour le niveau de nos
élèves bien sûr mais cela étant dit la
crise elle elle a commencé depuis depuis
longtemps encore une fois si vous prenez
la situation d'un pays comme la france
le décrochage du niveau scolaire
français prenez la dernière enquête team
ce qui montre le niveau des élèves en
mathématiques nous arrivons les derniers
d'europe nous sommes très très loin dans
l' ocde y compris de pays qui pourtant
ont des niveaux de vie et des structures
étatiques bien moins
- financés que les nôtres ça s'explique
malgré les nombreuses réformes de
nombreuses causes la difficulté de
relations entre les parents et les
enseignants la réforme menée par un jean
michel blanquer malheureusement à
contribuer beaucoup à cette difficulté
parce que comme le baccalauréat est
maintenant en contrôle continu est les
parents exigent des enseignants qu'ils
donnent de bonnes notes à leurs enfants
parce que ses notes sur la condition de
l'avenir de leurs enfants et de
l'orientation future de la tension est
de plus en plus et de plus en plus forte
ce que le sujet le sujet majeur encore
une fois c'est de retrouver le sens du
travail de l'enseignant d'abord
retrouver une sorte de reconnaissance
collective à l'égard des enseignants
cette période de rentrée je pense qu'on
peut leur dire merci du travail qu'ils
font parce que c'est eux qui préparent
l'avenir de nos enfants et puis le sens
même de ce qu'il y a deux projets
politiques dans l'enseignement charles
péguy disaient les crises de
l'enseignement ne sont pas des crises de
l'enseignement ce sont des crises de la
vie quand une société ne peut pas
enseigner c'est qu'elle ne sait pas sans
saigner elle même c'est qu'elle a honte
d'elle même et je pense que c'est
vraiment à cette racine là qu'il faut
chercher la crise de l'école mais vous
et vous esquissez quand même peut-être
aussi une piste les deux systèmes
scolaires qui résistent le mieux en
europe c'est la finlande et l'irlande
qui sont réputés penser le métier
d'enseignant à l'échelle de
l'établissement plus que l'individu donc
c'est vraiment l'autonomisation des
établissements etc c'est ce que vous
c'est ce que vous préconisez finalement
oui parce que je trouve une très grande
centralisation et une très grande
fixation aussi sur des notes pour
avancer dans les systèmes éducatifs et
une toxiques pour les jeunes et aussi
pour les essais plissement auxi on parle
de la santé mentale des nos jeunes
d'été toujours poussé à avoir des
meilleures notes pour réussir dans la
vie parce que il y à en voir seulement
une piste pour les succès ça leur pousse
dans des crises d santé mentale ces
questions est ce qu'elle mobilis est
question d'éducation est ce qu'elle
mobilise assez nos dirigeants qui pour
certains alors je ne sais pas si c'est
le cas on a une marque mais en france on
le sait ont choisi l'enseignement privé
pour leurs enfants c'est donc
l'enseignement public qui clairement est
sacrifiée alors je reprocherais pas à
quelqu'un d'avoir choisi l'enseignement
privé mais de donner à ses enfants ce
qu'ils refusent enfants des autres et là
pour le coup il ya évidemment un vrai
problème je me souviens pendant le
quinquennat de françois hollande quand
la majorité socialiste votait la
suppression du latin pour les élèves de
l'enseignement public beaucoup des
députés qui votait ces textes avaient
leurs enfants dans des établissements
privés voire parfois privées très
sélectif le latin était la règle donc il
ya quelque chose d'absolument
contradictoire pour soutenir
l'enseignement public l'école publique
mais il faut bien sûr relevé l'école
publique et je crois que ça passe il n'y
a pas de contradiction entre relevé
l'école publique c'est à dire l'école
pour tous les enfants de notre pays bas
l'argent quand même c'est le même argent
faut peut-être énervé des choix aussi
faible allure données et le fait de
redonner à l'école publique un peu de
liberté un peu d'autonomie comme on le
disait à l'instant de s'inspirer aussi
de ce qui fonctionne de se remettre avec
humilité à regarder ce qui marque moi je
pense en france à toutes ces initiatives
beaucoup de gens qui créent leurs
propres écoles les la fondation
espérance banlieue dans les banlieues
l'espérance ruralité dans les dents les
la france périphérique pour pour les
jeunes qui sont en train de décrocher
dans ces quartiers difficiles tout cela
on devrait s'en inspirer pour pouvoir
reconstruire un enseignement public qui
qui fonctionne en faisant de nouveau
confiance au professeur confiance au
chef d'établissement et aujourd'hui on
fait l'exact inverse c'est à dire que ce
que le gouvernement a fait dans les
dernières années c'est au contraire
mettre sous le boisseau toute la liberté
et pédagogique la liberté des
enseignants dans leur classe mais aussi
la liberté de ceux qui justement se
lancent dans des projets de cette nature
le contrôle de l'instruction en famille
voir la quasi suppression de
l'instruction en famille qui pose un
vrai problème y compris du point de vue
de l'état de droit c'est à dire que les
parents eux mêmes ne sont plus
responsabiliser dans leur rapport à
leurs enfants je dis pas que ça devrait
être un modèle universalisable mais je
dis que c'est important justement pour
que l'enseignement public sur relève que
vous dites devenu professeur c'est c'est
quand même un beau métier c c'est le
métier de l'avenir on sera pas remplacés
par des machines c'est impossible oui
c'est les métiers un des métiers des
plus importants pour notre avenir en
europe le problème c'est que c'est pas
en grand projet politique d'aidé donner
l'argent nécessaire à nos écoles à nozay
nos universités à la recherche
européenne est ce nécessaire qu'une
politiciens mais ça au niveau national
regardant dans le miroir et disent que
pour l'avenir pour nos enfants il faut
redonner de l'argent ou moi ne pas
retirer de l'argent pour des l'éduction
les mots de la fin merci à vous de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine et vous restez sur nos
antennes pour la suite des programmes à
très bientôt
[Musique]